Daniel: Hello and welcome.
It's February 27, 2023.
We're here active Inference lab
bookstream number 2.1 with Thomas Parr as
well as Terry and Ali.
So thank you all for joining.
This should be a very fun discussion.
And let's go first by way of of
introduction and beginning to thomas,
welcome and please, how did you come to
write this textbook in collaboration with
Pazulo and Friston?
Thomas: Well, again, thank you very much
for having me here.
How did we come to write the textbook?
Good question.
I think Giovanni was the person who
really had the idea and pushed for this.
But I think Carl had already previously
been approached by the editor who ended
up managing application of the book.
And when Giovanni had the idea that this
would be a really useful contribution, he
and I had a number of discussions about
it both in London and in Rome where he's
based, and sort of put out a plan and
sort of came up with something that we
hoped would be useful for the community.
I suppose part of the reason why we
thought it'd be a useful thing to do is
that active inference is a very
multidisciplinary type field that draws a
lot from lots of different domains.
And I think one of the struggles we all
had when we started out in it and I think
certainly what students and people who
are interested in the topics say to us is
that it's often quite difficult trying to
find all of these different topics,
trying to find the right background when
they don't all come from one field.
So putting it all together in one book
with a consistent notation, consistent
language, and trying to make it complete,
we hoped would just make the field a
little bit more accessible to others who
wanted to get involved.
Daniel: How did this dovetail or
integrate with your own education and
research directions, like what phases or
stages were you moving through while this
discussion was happening?
Thomas: Well, I think so.
When we initially started discussing it,
it must have been probably the last year
of my PhD.
So by that stage I've spent two to three
years sort of getting to grips with
active inference.
Having spent being relatively recent in
terms of learning some of the key
material myself, I think it was quite a
good stage to be at in terms of thinking
about what I would have wanted to know a
few years previously.
The actual writing of the book then
carried on over the next year or two.
And so by that stage I was back in
clinical training as well, which I think
is also a useful perspective in terms of
some of the later chapters in thinking
about application of active
infrastructure models in the context of
clinical conditions and psychiatry and
neurology and those sorts of areas.
Daniel: That's actually a really
interesting note.
How did the clinical experiences give a
perspective on the book or how did the
book or your learning in these abstract
and theoretical domains give a different
insight in the clinical setting?
Thomas: It's a good question, and I think
you're right to highlight the bi
directionality of it.
Both are useful in different ways.
I think for me, the clinical setting is
quite useful in terms of thinking, first
of all, interacting with a different sort
of audience.
So people who may be much more skilled on
the clinical side of things maybe have
less experience on the mathematical,
computational side of things, but may
still find concepts very useful.
So from that side of things, it's quite a
useful exercise in being able to
communicate things.
And then there's sort of the interaction
on the patient side of things and trying
to I think it makes a big difference.
First of all, interacting with patients
has an impact on how you might think
about the interesting questions and the
things you might want to use to inference
for.
But also having an understanding of
principles behind it helps you, I think,
formulate your questions about how
individual patients might present or the
reasons for that.
I think it's a useful way of thinking
about, I mean, I suppose on two levels.
So one in terms of understanding
understanding particular sorts of
pathology, in terms of the inferences
that might have gone wrong, but also in
terms of understanding your own active
inferential processes when you're trying
to work out what's going on yourself,
asking the right sort of questions, to
gather the right sort of information and
test those internal hypotheses.
I think that's a very useful way of
thinking about being a doctor.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thomas: Yeah.
Daniel: A lot to say about that.
The Bayesian optimal differential
diagnosis.
Ali or Terry, on any of these thoughts,
do you have any questions or comments you
want to raise there or any followups.
Ali: Well, yes, actually, I just wanted
to ask what are the intended audience of
the book and what do you think are the
minimum prerequisites for going through
the whole book?
Because I'm sure you'll agree that even
today the intersection between the people
who are well versed in mathematics and
the people who have a solid background
in, say, neurobiology are quite narrow.
So what's the solution here, and what did
you think about the organizational
structure of the book that could
accommodate various audiences?
Thomas: Again, another really good
question, and I think you're right to
highlight that.
That intersection is relatively narrow
and there are lots of people who I think
struggle to feel involved in those kinds
of discussions, and you're absolutely
right to say that.
And I think one of the solutions is the
sorts of things that you guys are doing
in terms of setting up these reading
groups, trying to open that up, trying to
provide ethical, educational resources.
I think that's really very important.
In terms of the specific questions about
the book itself, who's the audience well
and what are the prerequisites?
I think it sort of depends what you want
to get out of this and what your purpose
is in reading it.
So some aspects of the book, I suppose,
will appeal more to some audiences and
others to other kinds of audience.
I would hope that the readership or the
audience is relatively broad because
we've tried to provide as much background
as we can on sort of the mathematical and
the neurobiological side of things to try
and complement the skill.
Set of whoever's not in that
intersection, who comes to it, who may
need a bit more sort of neurobiological
grounding or who may need a bit more
mathematical and technical grounding.
But I think ultimately, like with most
textbooks, you don't necessarily need to
come to it thinking, I'm going to
understand everything in this book when I
come away from it.
Some people may want to, but other
people, depending upon what they want to
get out of it, they might say, actually,
what I really want to get out of this is
an understanding of some of the kind of
message passing as it manifests in the
brain.
Whereas other people might come to us and
say, actually, I already understand a bit
about that, and what I want to get out of
this is to understand a bit more of the
technical detail.
If you're a roboticist coming to this, it
probably doesn't matter too much about
how things are implemented in the brain.
If you're a neurobiologist coming to
this, you may not need to know the
details of the implementation as long as
you can understand it conceptually.
And I hope the organization, particularly
putting things like appendices of the
detailed information at the back, tries
to keep most of the text a bit more
accessible.
The early chapters being relatively light
on the technical material and building up
the concepts before then moving into the
more technical aspects.
Daniel: About the chapters.
Actually, just take a quick look at the
chapters we're in the Koda document that
we use, so perhaps you could just say one
or a few sentences on each chapter.
What's the short of each chapter?
What is it doing in this ten chapter
work?
Thomas: Testing my memory.
Daniel: Now, the titles are there.
The queues are there.
Thomas: Titles are there.
Daniel: Epistemic queues are there?
Thomas: Okay, well, the overview is what
it says on the tin, the description of
what's to come in the subsequent chapters
to try and try and orientate people.
The low road and high road I think.
Again, giovanni has to take credit for
this idea of saying actually, it's often
difficult to know where to begin when
you're trying to understand active
inference and the free energy principle
and the Bayesian brain and all those
sorts of things, because it seems like
there are so many potential starting
points, all of which, ultimately, I
think, get at the same thing.
But knowing where you begin is often
really quite difficult.
And so these two chapters were designed
to explicitly acknowledge that
difficulty.
So the idea of the low road is to say,
well, let's take a pragmatic perspective
where we take ideas that have developed
in neuroscience based upon our
understanding of the brain and of
psychology, and models that have been
developed to explain those things.
And let's take those to their conclusion,
which is, in essence, the free energy
principle, which active inference lab the
idea of using our internal models both to
drive behavior and to understand what's
going on in the world around us.
The high road perspective was designed to
take a different approach to that.
And instead of starting from what's
already being developed and the sort of
natural trajectory in the neurosciences,
the High Road chapter was more saying
let's start from first principles as much
as we can.
And it was a tricky balance to try and
make sure that we didn't go too far in
depth, that we put people off by the
third chapter, but enough that people
might get a bit of a conceptual sense of
where you might go with this.
And here we sort of started from the kind
of physics, the cells organization, the
ideas that come underneath that, and how
those ideas can then feed back into the
same idea of accidents that the
neuroscientists and psychology seem to
have arrived at relatively naturally.
But chapter four is when things start
getting a bit more technical and starts
dealing with the specifics that I think
most people would want to know if they
were implementing these models
themselves.
So trying to understand exactly how you
construct an internal model, how you
specify it, write it down mathematically,
how you, how you perform inference with
those, how you understand message passing
schemes.
Chapter five then takes a step back and
thinks, well, in the context of the
brain, in the context of neurobiology,
what do those things actually look like?
How do we understand those inferential
processes of different kinds of
generative models in terms of what we
know about message passing and synaptic
communication?
And those five chapters together really
are the first part of the book and the
subsequent five chapters really then take
you through the idea of actually applying
those ideas in in particular domains.
So chapter six is sort of the overview
chapter, looking at the rest of it and
it's really setting out.
If you wanted to sit down and design a
model, either conceptually or
computationally, these are the steps you
would have to go through to construct
that.
And then chapters seven and eight take
you through that sort of recipe for
several examples, building up different
concepts, both the models designed in
discrete time where you're formulating
things with a sequence of events, and
models formulated in continuous time.
We work with continuous dynamical systems
and differential equations.
Chapter Nine as I mentioned before, one
of my interests is in the clinical domain
and trying to understand what sort of
models people use to perform inference
how those can go wrong.
And part of the research on that is
thinking, well, how do we then fit these
models and use them to actually draw
inferences about what's going on,
particular individuals or groups of
individuals?
And then chapter ten takes the broadest
perspective and looks at how that relates
to a range of other theories and ideas
both in the neurosciences and beyond.
And then I'm sure the appendices speak
for themselves.
Daniel: Awesome.
Great overview.
Let's come back to our questions.
So you laid out that the first half of
the book is about learning and the second
half of the book is about applying, and
it begins with that recipe.
So if chapter six is the recipe, as a
chef and sous chef yourself, what else
have you found was important in the
restaurant?
What does your full stack active
inference modeling look like?
And maybe summarizing in six or going
beyond what was in six like, what have
you found to be important as part of the
modeling journey, especially with teams
where people might have like, different
levels of domain specific knowledge or
active knowledge?
Thomas: I like the restaurant analogy,
actually.
The first thing that anybody needs to do
if they're setting up a restaurant or a
model is thinking about who their
customers are and what they might want.
And so in the scientific domain, you're
thinking, well, what sort of journal am I
planning on submitting this to?
What sort of questions are the
communities who read those journal
articles interested in?
And I think that's a really important
first step so that, you know, what I'm
actually trying to do with this model,
what's not such a good idea often,
although you can find interesting things
by doing it, is to say, well, I'm going
to develop a model and work out what it's
for later on.
You can end up sort of tying yourself up
a little bit by doing that.
Although there is value in exploring, as
I think we would all agree, I suppose in
terms of ingredients, it's relatively
straightforward and deliberately so.
I suppose the idea of these sorts of
models is that they should be relatively
accessible, relatively easy to construct,
without having to make use of large
supercomputers or anything like that.
A lot of the models that I develop can be
run on a laptop, fairly
straightforwardly.
So obviously, just picking your computing
language and how you're going to
construct that, there are now a couple of
different options out there, matlab being
the one that I think is most well
developed, but now lots of people
developing Python based implementations
of accident schemes and particularly in
the Markov decision process realm.
So that gives you, I suppose, that some
of the key ingredients, but then it's
really sitting down and thinking, well,
how would I now actually construct this
model?
And the key question, I think often is if
you have a particular phenomena or a
particular task in mind, that you want
the model to perform it's thinking, well,
how would I go about actually
constructing the data that's presented to
a participant performing that task, or
presented to an agent that's trying to
perform this task?
And if you can explain how those data are
generated, then you effectively have the
generative model that implicitly your
agent or your participant or whoever else
should be using to be able to perform
that task.
So really all you need to be able to do
is to work out how to create the
experimental stimuli.
And once you've done that, you've almost
already created your model.
And the rest comes from predefined,
preexisting inversion schemes that
actually minimize the free energy for
that model.
So at that stage it becomes relatively
straightforward.
I say relatively because as anybody has
experienced encoding knows, a lot of time
has spent debugging and throwing up
arrows and spending a while trying to
work out why with a bit of googling to
work out a solution around that.
I think those are all important parts of
the process.
Daniel: Awesome.
Ollie or Terry on that recipe and
modeling question, any thoughts on that?
Ali: Yeah, actually I also wanted to ask
if do you have a plan for extending the
codes or supplementary materials to
include other languages such as IMDP
packages or any other packages that might
come up later and would be widely used in
active inference?
Because as far as I know, there isn't any
specific GitHub repo or something
dedicated for this book so far.
So do you have any plans in developing
such a supplementary material for the
book?
Thomas: We don't at the moment.
It might be an interesting thing, I mean,
it might be a useful thing to be done by
the active inference community as well as
a way of sort of being engaged and
involved in it.
I suppose one of the difficulties of
doing that for a book is that often these
things move on so quickly, by the time it
comes out in a book, those packages have
moved on.
So I think it was useful for us to give a
simple example of Mathematic
implementation to demonstrate the
principles in one of the packages that
we've been involved in developing as part
of the SBM package, where we've been
involved in developing the active
routines as part of that.
And I think it's certainly a good idea
thinking about having other repositories
out there with all sorts of
demonstrations.
So the SBM package does have a range of
different demonstrations for different
sorts of implementations as well for
different kinds of models, which is a
really helpful resource.
And I often suggest to people that one of
the first ways of getting a sense of how
to build these models is to look at one
that's already been built and do their
best to break it, change things and make
it behave in different ways.
And so I think you're absolutely right to
say examples of the code and how it's
implemented are vital in bringing people
into this.
But yes, I think you're absolutely right
to say that it would be really helpful to
have both Python and Julia
implementations and all sorts of
different ways of doing it and examples
so that people can pick those up.
I agree completely.
Of course, one of the advantages of
Python and Julia is that they're open
source and you don't necessarily use an
academic license to use it, which again,
I think increases the number of people
who can access it.
Daniel: Giving an overview to someone who
might not have been following in the blow
by blow of our little literature corner
over the last few years.
How would you say active inference
modeling has evolved during your time in
this space?
Where are we at, just generally speaking
with applications?
What applications are developed or
possible today that when you were
starting your PhD seemed like they were
just implausible?
Thomas: I think if we go back a bit, I
suppose some of the earlier
implementations were almost all in the
continuous domain.
So they're all based upon things like the
generalized filtering type algorithms
that were initially developed as sort of
filtering methods to perform time series
inference.
Those things then equipped with an active
component than the cadence under the
earlier active inference type
simulations.
And a lot of that focused on things in
the movement domain, whether that be eye
movements or control of limbs.
To the extent that you can sort of
develop handwriting and those sorts of
things, one of the interesting things
that started to happen based upon that
was to think about how you then get
something that looks more sequential
emerged from those continuous dynamics.
And handwriting was actually a really
good example of that, where there were
some simulations developed in which the
continuous model effectively had
something a bit like a lot volter dynamic
in it.
The idea there being that you can sort of
lock volter dynamics are a kind of
dynamical system often used for modeling
things like predator prey interactions.
And the idea is that you get a peak in
terms of a predator population sorry,
prey population.
Followed by a peak in the prey the
predators as they eat the prey, causing
drop in the prey population.
But then as the predators die out of, the
prey come back and you get this sort of
sequence of peaks from predator prey.
Predator prey.
You can generalize that to then have
multiple different populations, each
preying on one of the mouths.
So you get this sequence of peaks over
time.
And that sort of emergence of sequences
from continuous dynamics, I think was one
of the key moves early on in terms of
thinking about things that are a bit more
cognitive in terms of how do I do this
and then this and this.
Andy Clark to plan and generate much more
purposeful type of behavior.
So that went so far until things moved
much more to an explicitly discrete or
sequential style of modeling.
That's when things like Markov decision
processes have started to be employed in
the active inference domain or partially
observed Markov decision processes.
So those are models that say, I assume my
world is a sequence of states over time,
one after another, each of which
generates some observations.
And from those observations, I can make
inferences about the states.
You can then say, well, if I can act upon
the world, I can change the sequence of
states as they evolve over time.
And by selecting different actions or
different ways, I can change that
sequence.
I'm effectively planning and making
decisions.
So that's, again, where you get into a
much more cognitive sort of domain.
Some of the key advances sort of early on
while I was doing my PhD.
Were the emergence of things like deep
hierarchical models of things like Markov
decision processes.
So here the idea was that in the world
around us, there are lots of things that
evolve over different sorts of time
scales.
One of the early examples of this was
reading the idea that when you move your
eyes around the page, you're sort of
looking at an individual word or the
letters within that word.
But that word is itself part of the
sentence.
And the time it takes you to infer what
the word is, is going to be much shorter
than the time it takes you to work out
what's going on in terms of the sentence,
the sentence and the paragraph, and the
paragraph on the page, and the page and
the book, et cetera.
So there's a whole hierarchy of different
time scales in the world around us.
And one way of accounting for that
relatively simply in these sorts of
models is to simply stack them on top of
one another.
So the outcomes you're now predicting
from one of the Markov decision process
type models I was describing now reflects
a sequence of very fast states.
And each of those states yes, exactly.
Is the graphics of this.
And then each of those outcomes predicts
another sequence of very fast states.
So what you're left with is, at the very
top level, a very slow progression of
state after state after state.
For each of those states, which might be
the sentence, you then have the word
words in that sentence beneath it.
And then for each of those words, you
might have each of the letters sorry, in
each of the letters in that word.
And so that then sort of expanded the
range of things that we can do in terms
of how we give some sort of deep temporal
structure to the kinds of models we
develop.
Sometimes people refer to that as kind of
breaking the Markov property.
So for those who aren't familiar with
this, the Markov property is the idea
that each step in time depends only upon
the step immediately previous to it.
That all you need to know about the next
time step is what's happening at the
current time step.
Nothing else in the past is useful once
you know that.
And people often suggest that means that
these processes are effectively
memoryless.
Because it's only where I am now that
matters, it's not what was happening well
into the past.
By having a hierarchical structure where
you have a higher level state that is
more slowly changing that's
contextualizing, what's going on at the
lower level, it means that the fast
sequence of changes is actually dependent
upon something much slower that's
happening and that in itself is dependent
upon something much slower.
And that gives you a sort of memory, it
allows the Markov property to be broken.
Like I said, we're sort of starting off
with continuous, the emergence of
discrete from continuous, the explicit
modeling of continuous models, decision
making and the sort of exploration and
exploitation type trade offs that you get
once you treat planning as being an
inference process.
The idea that you can then stack these
things hierarchically and have a range of
different time scales that break the
Markov process allow us to think about
things like memory and working memory.
And then I suppose one of the next stages
was the combination or the reintroduction
of the continuous models as the lowest
level of one of these hierarchies.
The idea that actually it's all very well
being able to make decisions, but at some
stage you need to implement those
decisions in a world that's made up of
physics and muscle lengths and continuous
sensory inputs.
And so putting these sort of hybrid
models together where you can use your
decisions to then predict short sequences
and trajectories defined in a continuous
domain.
And I suppose since then there have been
a range of further developments, active
inference, lab and map setting and a
range of developments in a number of
other directions sort of in parallel.
So some of those developments have been
thinking about implementation in other
languages.
Some of those developments have been
thinking about combination with methods
from deep learning and introduction of
variation, auto encoders and function,
approximators and amortized inference,
which a lot of people in the robotics
community have been pioneering,
particularly that would be one direction
that things have been developed in.
And I suppose the other direction that's
seen a lot of development recently has
been the sort of underlying principles,
the physics that underwrites active the
principles and how you justify the sort
of dynamics and where free energy comes
from as a concept and why it's useful in
understanding how systems behave.
So I hope that wasn't too much all at
once, but that was a sort of run through
of some of the developments that spring
to mind over the last few years.
Daniel: Awesome.
Perry or Ali, any comments on that quick
historical review.
Ali: Again, I had another question
regarding actually it's a question out of
mere curiosity.
Did you have any specific reason for
adopting this particular mathematical
notation throughout the book?
Because it seems like it somewhat
diverges from the notations used in some
of the well known papers in the
literature.
And I know active inference notation is
not consistently used across the
literature, but even in the papers that
came out after the publication of this
book written by Professor Prison or
others, I don't see this specific
notation used a lot in those papers.
So I just wanted to ask about the reasons
behind this choice.
Thomas: Okay.
I think you're absolutely right to say
that it's not always been used
consistently.
And it's worth saying that there are a
couple of different tensions that affect
this.
So one is the idea that in a lot of
papers that are published because it's
only dealing with an aspect of active
inference and not trying to put it all
together, they can sort of use a notation
that may be the same as notation you
might use in another field without worry
that people will get conflicted and
misinterpret one variable for another
because everything's just defined within
that one domain.
Another aspect to it is that depending
upon the paper in question and the
audience is aimed at, sometimes the
notation is designed to match what might
be used in that broader field, whereas
we've tried to try to make it as
consistent as possible across different
fields.
Were there any particular notations that
you were thinking of?
Do I can help clarify.
Yes.
Ali: For example, as just a very simple
example, using ata for external states
instead of x that's being used, or S and
A for active states and sensory states or
other kinds of uses of lowercase matrices
and uppercase matrices, which is used
differently in a paper such as step by
step tutorial, active inference lab and
these kinds of notational divergences.
Thomas: Okay.
Yes, there's some quite nice
illustrations.
So things like A and S, which, as you
say, are often used in some of the more
physics orientated papers.
Unfortunately, if you use those in a
Markov decision process paper, people
will interpret those as being states and
parameters of a likelihood matrix.
So unfortunately, we couldn't use those
same letters without causing more
confusion.
So what we try to do there is to focus
more on the sort of practical inference
side of things, of the actual
implementations we tend to use of
accidents in particular problem
settings.
And there when you're constructing a
generative model, particularly if it's in
the continuous domain, I'll often use X
as being the states that I have to infer,
which from the perspective of the physics
type papers are the external states, the
things that are having an effect on my
sensory states.
I can't remember whether we used Y or O,
the sensory states or the data in the
book as you think it's Y.
Okay.
And that sort of fits with the idea of
using it in the continuous domain.
Where in a lot of settings when you're
trying to predict sensory data, often why
will end up being the variable that we
end up using.
So I appreciate that it can be confusing,
sort of jumping between different
resources, but what we strove for in this
one was internal consistency as much as
we could and trying not to overload
specific variables or symbols.
Ali: Thank you.
Daniel: Thanks.
Figure 4.3.
We found ourself coming back to again and
again.
It for Sages, chapters seven and eight.
And it lays out discrete time on top and
continuous time on the bottom in terms of
their structural similarities.
But also they have some really important
differences.
Could you just, as you see it, how do the
discrete time and the continuous time
models have similarities and differences
such that you can lay them out in a
graphically or visually similar way, yet
there's also some key differences, for
example, in what each of the nodes dean.
So how are they similar and different?
And what did you hope to illustrate by
laying out Figure 4.3 this way?
Thomas: So I think the reason that they
can be seen as similar is that
effectively what you're trying to do in
both cases to represent a trajectory.
We're trying to represent how something
evolves in time.
And that something may be the states s in
the discrete time or they may be the
trajectory of some hidden state x in the
continuous domain.
And when you're trying to say how do I
actually put together a set of numbers
that tell me how something's evolved or
evolving, there are a couple of different
ways you can do that.
One is to say I'm going to tell you where
it is at time one and then I'm going to
tell you where it is at time two and then
at time three, et cetera, et cetera.
And that's a perfectly legitimate and
perfectly reasonable way of writing down
a trajectory.
It obviously misses out all the times
between time one and time two, which may
or may not be significant depending upon
what the problem is you're dealing with.
The second way that we approach it is to
say, well, you can use what's known as a
Taylor series approximation or a Taylor
series or a polynomial expression or that
trajectory.
So essentially what we're saying there is
that you just construct a function that
follows the shape of that trajectory over
time.
And you can construct that function by
saying, well, let's look at where I am
now at this point in time and my
position, how am I changing over time?
If you just took those two variables
together, you just have a straight line
telling you where you are and where
you're going to be.
If you then take account of the
acceleration, you may even have a curve
line which says that I'm here now, I'm
going to be there then.
And as you add in more and more elements
to this, so the rate of change of the
velocity and the rate of change of the
rate of change of the velocity, et
cetera, and just add in more and more
rates of change, you effectively get a
more and more precise function, telling
you, at least locally, around where you
are now, where you're going to be at
various other times.
So that difference, either using Taylor
series coefficients, which are just
successive rates of change, or by using a
sequence of states over time, are what's
illustrated in the lower and upper
graphics here, respectively.
Each of those things has, as you said,
they have a lot in common in terms of
their structure, in terms of the number
of numbers you need to be able to
describe them, but each has their
advantages and disadvantages depending
upon what you're trying to actually
model.
And I think for me, I tend to think of
the sequence of categorical states over
time as being quite useful in thinking
about anything to do with decisionmaking,
deciding between alternatives, thinking
about sequences like language and words
and even sequences in terms of the eye
movements you make looking in one place,
then the next, then the next, rather than
continuously moving your eyes around
space in a smooth fashion.
Whereas the process of interpreting
sensory data that's coming in from your
retina or from your stretch receptors or
whatever else or in terms of actually
driving action that changes continuous
variables in the world there I think it's
much more useful to be able to describe
things in terms of a continuous number
and those sorts of continuous
trajectories that you can get through
using these Taylor Series type
approximations, which often referred to
in this context as generalized
coordinates of motion.
Daniel: Awesome.
Cool.
Well, another figure that we come back to
again and again tucked away in chapter
nine, but giving a lot of context is
Figure 9.1 on what is termed metabasian
inference.
So could you describe what is happening
in this figure and is this exactly as
every empirical ethologist is going to
agree with?
Is this controversial?
Is this novel?
So what is it doing for active inference
when we conceptualize our empirical task
structurally like this?
And do you think that that is exactly how
ethologists have long seen this topic or
is this something contentious?
Thomas: I think so.
I'll talk through the figure but then you
can tell me if that's how ethologists
traditionally look at it and whether it's
contentious.
I'll be interested there.
So the idea behind this figure is to
highlight that when dealing in psychology
or neuroscience fields, where you're
trying to understand how a particular
system is behavior or how it's
essentially what's going on in the mind
or the brain or the nervous system of
some creature that is behaving in some
way.
There are two levels at which you can
look at it.
One is saying, well, from my perspective
as the experimenter, what are the data
I'm measuring and that may be behavior
measurements from that creature.
It may be taking electrophysiological
measurements.
It may be asking it a question if it's a
patient in that clinical setting.
And I'm essentially now trying to
optimize my model of this system.
Now, in the neurosciences and in the
settings I've outlined above, the kind of
system we're interested in is the sort of
system that has its own model of other
sorts of system.
And so the kinds of questions we're
interested in, the kind of parameters
we're interested in, are things like the
prior belief that this creature has about
this thing or how precise it thinks its
data are.
And so the parameters I'm now asking a
question about are the parameters of the
beliefs of another system.
So the outside box here, the one that the
parameters are going into, the
experimental stimuli are going into, and
the observed behavior are coming out of,
is essentially my model of how this other
system behaves.
Now, the inside box here, the one in the
dotted line or the dashed line, that now
represents the model that that system has
to understand the world around it.
And so when we construct our model that
contains another model inside it, and by
saying, if this creature believed this,
this is how they would make inferences
about their environment and generate
behavior, I can now predict the behavior
I would observe if this creature believed
this thing.
So the subjective objective idea is that
the objective model is the experimenter
and its beliefs and the experimenters
beliefs and the observations they make by
measuring what the participant or
experimental subject does.
And the subjective model is the
participants model of the world around
them.
So that, I think, would be my summary of
how this figure works and the idea it's
trying to get across.
Now, you can tell me how ethologists may
disagree with that or agree with it, or
what they'd find controversial.
Daniel: I'll give a thought, and Ali or
Terry, feel free to give a follow up or a
thought.
I don't think, in principle it's
contentious or dissentious.
However, there might be an explicit or an
implicit belief, of course, ironically,
that we can simply take some of these
parameters coming into our experimental
setup and even the selection of
experimental stimuli.
We can take those as simply given, which
is a very frequentist perspective.
And then on the observed behavior, we can
simply use descriptive statistics.
We'll characterize the predefined groups
according to the one experiment we ran.
We'll do the Ttest, we'll do the ANOVA.
We'll come up with a p value.
It's going to be frequentism all the way
forward.
So even if we're doing frequentism about
a generative model, there's a sense that
if we just clamp down on our experiment
and treat it as handed down without
error, instead of being actually drawn
from distributions of possible
experiments, we could have done.
If we clamp down upstream of the
experiments, we'll just be able to
describe and ultimately publish without
needing to look at what else could have
happened.
And I think this diagram and also the
very subtle dashed line around even the
bigger box suggests that just like the
active clinician engaging with a
conversation or the active experimenter
also engaging iteratively over their
system of interest, that itself is an
adaptive epistemic process where, yes,
you could simplify it by treating the
parameters and the stimuli sequences as
simply given, but then you don't have
access to the generative model.
That actually is the generative process
for the subjective model.
So summarize in principle uncontentious,
however, sometimes discordant with the
ways that behavior experiments are
conceptualized, planned and analyzed.
One reason why it's helpful because
during the book we try to stay on the
road, on the high road or the low road.
But when we're in discussions it's almost
like there's a whole roadmap and people
have their own backgrounds and questions
and it kind of comes together with all
these different topics that people are
curious about, ultimately that bring them
to active inference.
So going to this metabasian figure helps
in some ways situate how the authors are
seeing this entire process of
experimental design, observation and
cognitive modeling.
And that was unpacked also in the recent
Map territory fallacy fallacy work.
Ali or Terry, any thoughts or questions
in our last ten minutes?
Is there a figure you want to look at?
Or we can go to some other places.
Ali: Maybe we can ask the missing
figure.
I think it was in figure seven.
Daniel: Point yes or something 7.2 in the
lower left.
Thomas: So this was actually corrected by
I don't know quite how it ended up
vanishing, but it was corrected in one of
the later print versions.
I'll save it from the version I got in
front of me now and I can show you what
it would have looked like, but apologies
for that.
Which figure is it?
Daniel: 7.2 on page 128.
Thomas: Fortunately, I picked up a copy
of the book that doesn't have it.
Daniel: So there have already been one
and a half fractal dimensions of
printing.
Thomas: Yes.
Unfortunately I don't think that one's
corrected yet in the online copy.
Essentially what would have appeared in
that figure or what did in some of the
later printing versions is the errors
that are driving the updates to the
states in the plot above.
Now because the errors here are
effectively are the free energy gradients
or the negative free energy gradients.
So essentially as you go down the free
energy gradient, you're effectively
minimizing your error.
So what that means in Active is that the
errors would effectively be the rates of
change of the states and the plot above.
So if you take the states in the plot
above and you imagine what the rates of
change of each of those lines are, that's
what you would get in the plot below.
Daniel: Well, on this same kind of topic,
in chapter seven, we're in the discrete
time generative models, and a little bit
less so here, but in the latter models
here in 7.13 and in what we just looked
at in 7.2, where are these continuous
interpolations coming from if it's a
discrete time model?
Thomas: That's a good point.
So I suppose there's an important
distinction to be made here.
There's the distinction between the
things that are being inferred, which are
happening over discrete steps in time.
And then there's the inference process
itself, which deals in probabilities
which are themselves continuous.
They can vary in this case anywhere
between zero and one and the time over
which that inference happens.
To give you an example, if you imagine
that the way you're analyzing this figure
at the moment is by making a series of
the category movements, you're not sort
of continuously moving your eyes from one
plot to the next.
You're making a series of rapid ballistic
movements that take you from one to the
next.
And effectively, every time your eyes
stand still, you have a new data point
that you're now trying to analyze.
You can imagine that between that every
time your eyes stay still, everything
else in your brain doesn't just stop.
So once you've got that new data point,
your brain now has some time to simulate
that data point to draw inferences about
what it's seeing there.
And those inferences happen through the
continuous dynamics of what's happening
in your neurons and various networks
across your brain.
So you can think of the continuous
changes that are happening for each state
as not being changes in the world that
we're trying to infer, not being changes
in the data point I'm currently looking
at.
So the changes in my beliefs about it
before I then sample the next data
point.
Daniel: Interesting.
I have a few more figure based quick
questions, but Terry, do you want to
bring up anything or just give any
remarks?
No worries.
If not.
Terry: I am very much just trying to
understand these concepts, so I don't
make any pretense having any deep
understanding.
But the key thing that interests me is
how you jump from this sense of how we
update our predictions into the clinical
realm.
I'm interested in pain medicine, and I
see neuroplastic pain as very much a
mistaken prediction based on often
misinterpretation by medical
professionals and the information that
they give to patients.
And I'm really intrigued by the
potential.
Thomas: For.
Terry: Using these concepts to give
patients an architecture in which they
can start to understand that they have
some agency in altering their future
predictions and really change in their
experience of their pain.
As you're a clinician, I'd be really
intrigued to get your sense of where this
is going in that type of clinical realm.
Thomas: I think that's a really nice
example as well, thinking about attitudes
towards pain and particular kinds of
pain, particularly when there isn't
obvious tissue damage that can be
identified that's causing that pain.
But that still is obviously a very real
sensation to people who are experiencing
it.
And I think it generalizes to a number of
other conditions.
And probably there's an overlap with
things like functional neurological
disorders, probably a number of medically
unexplained symptoms and things where
there is a huge amount of overlap in
these sorts of processes where you can't
necessarily directly identify a big
structural lesion of any sort.
But clearly the way the nervous system is
working, something isn't quite right.
Pain I think, is an interesting example,
particularly because pain is never a real
thing out there in the world, is it?
I mean, it's always an inference.
And so I think that's one of the first
things to say to anybody, regardless of
whether you've got pain because you've
lost a leg or whatever else, there's no
such thing as pain as an external state.
It is just your inference, your
explanation for the signals that are
coming in from your body.
Now, one of the important concepts that I
think comes into all of these sorts of
syndromes and probably many others as
well, is the idea of precision.
The idea that the data I predict sensory
data coming in, in addition to estimating
what those data are going to look like, I
also have to estimate how confident I am
in what they're going to look like.
If I'm not very confident or I think I'm
dealing in something that's very noisy,
then I can actually discount a lot of
that signal.
Whereas if I believe that it's all
extremely reliable, very clean data
that's coming in, then I want to put a
lot of weight on that.
And another way of saying that is that
there are some things I pay attention to
and some things I don't.
And just saying it's reliable data is
just a matter of saying I'm going to
attempt to it.
Now, it might be that in a number of
these different syndromes, what's going
on is that our bodies have overestimated
the precision, overestimated how clean
the data are coming in from particular
body part.
And that's why we then overinterpret any
signals to coming in as if they are
painful.
And active inference we draw from those
signals are just too confident and too
driven by something that they shouldn't
be.
An example I often like to use in
clinical discussions is that if I told
you to pay attention now to the feeling
that your left sock is having on your
left big toe, you can probably feel it,
but you were completely unaware of it
before.
But now if I say continue to pay
attention to that andy Clark on paying
attention to that and you're unable to
pay attention away from it anymore, if
you felt that all the time, it would feel
unusual, it would feel wrong and maybe a
miscalation of precision in that way,
maybe what's going on in a lot of these
sorts of conditions.
Partly, I think it's often interesting
that in some of these people there was at
some stage an injury or something that
affected that body part.
And you can imagine that if you went
through a period of illness where you did
have tissue damage and were in pain for
that reason, it might direct your
attention to that, and you may have a
learned deployment of attention towards
that area that might persist even after
the insult and the damage is resolved.
And again, maybe it's that sort of
persistent mislearning of how precise
things are that leads to the continued
experience of pain, even when there's
nothing sort of externally causing it
anymore.
So I think just having a sense of
inference and the idea that all our
perceptions of the world around us are
ultimately inferences says that if we
change our model in some way, we're able
to adapt and change.
And plasticity in our brains and spinal
cords can be exploited, then we can also
correct those misleading models and
hopefully resolve those sorts of symptoms
and syndromes.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you.
Well, we are, at the very close, really
appreciative, Thomas, of how much we were
able to cover.
What are your closing words or thoughts,
potentially, to someone who has listened
to this 1 hour discussion as their
appetizer before joining the par at All
Restaurant service?
Thomas: Well, I've enjoyed the
discussion.
Thank you for having me here.
I'll reiterate what I said earlier, that
I think one of the key things in making
this field more accessible to more people
are these sort of reading groups, the
ideas of trying to create these
educational resources and to unpack and
discuss these things.
And I'm impressed by all the
infrastructure you've put together and by
everything you've managed to achieve by
doing this.
So I'd certainly encourage anyone who's
interested to join up to your reading
groups, and I hope they get something out
of it and out of the book.
Daniel: Thanks, ali?
Ali: Well, yes, actually, since the
beginning of the first cohort, this book
has practically become a part of our life
that we love and cherish.
And it's amazing to see how with each
iteration of our reading group, it gives
rise to a whole different set of
questions and discussions.
And actually, I'm a firm believer in this
famous quote, I don't know by whom, which
says that the sign of a great book is not
how many answers it provides, but rather
how many thought provoking questions it
engenders.
So based on that criterion, and judging
by the variety of questions brought up
during our live discussions as a kind of
empirical evidence for that, I think it's
probably safe to say that this is truly a
great book.
So congratulations on that.
And thank you.
Thomas: Thank you very much.
Daniel: Great closing thoughts.
So, Thomas, thank you again.
You're welcome back anytime.
Thanks, Ali and Terry for all the great
participation.
And till next time.
Thomas: Bye.